for the second time in less than a year
colombian store owner jairo games and
his family had to flee escalating
violence between armed groups
last march they left venezuela for
colombia's arauca region they're now
here in the capital bogota searching for
help and shelter
we had a small store in venezuela and at
times we sold things to farc dissidents
that was enough to be targeted as
supporters when a killing started last
week the brother of a commander arrived
and told us you have two options you can
come with us meaning become part of the
guerrilla forces or you're going to have
to leave because the e-l-n will kill you
the year ln is colombia's largest
remaining rebel group after the farc
made peace with the government in 2016
but dissident factions of the farc have
since appeared and in recent weeks
violence in the lawless region along the
border with venezuela has been growing
some 30 people have been killed since
the beginning of the year while others
have been kidnapped or forcibly
recruited or displaced
the fighting has created lots of fear
in the population
many people fear that the region is
going back to the
the armed conflict that they lived
between 2006 and 2010 between the ln and
the farc back then
and the humanitarian impact has been
really really severe the violence has
reached new levels since a long-standing
truce between the armed groups broke
down
the last war between the then farc
rebels and the year ln left a thousand
people dead and displaced almost 60
thousand the colombian government now
blames venezuela for the current
violence accusing the venezuelan
government of sheltering the armed
groups in their territory something the
government in caracas denies
people from towns along the border have
taken to the streets demanding peace
colombian president ivan duke is
deploying two battalions to regain
control of the region but some experts
believe more troops won't solve the
problem
aruka still has a huge unresolved armed
conflict and people have no confidence
in the state
it already has the highest amount of
soldiers per square metre in colombia
sending 600 more troops will not make a
difference what's needed is to restart
peace negotiations with the eln
and until the trouble in arauca can be
contained the humanitarian crisis will
only continue to grow spreading here to
the capital and beyond alessandra
ampietti al jazeera bogota